bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce résumé
des deux premières parties du
championnat du monde entre magnus 15 sel
les fabiano caruana
dans cette première partie avec les
blancs on retrouve le challenger fabiano
caruana qui a joué une mauvaise un
mauvais milieu de partie dans une
défense sicilienne
il n'a pas réussi à concrétiser son
attaque le roi noir est parti sur les
dames les blondes ont jamais réussi à
l'attaqué et il se fait contre attaquer
sur les droits on se retrouve dans cette
position au 33e coulée noire vient de
jouer le coup damman g5 et pourchassés
probablement le cavalier blanc par le
coup à chaque le cavalier blanc qui est
parti tout de suite avec le kuga vih 2
il a anticipé le coup à chaque il aurait
probablement dû attendre quand même que
ce coût soit joué et là les noirs ont
raté très curieusement un coup très fort
coup qui aurait pu probablement gagner
tout de suite et le coup dames 5 qui
aurait permis à la dame noire de rentrer
dans le camp des blancs sur l'ale dame
sur la case b2 probablement pour
attaquer à la fois les pions c2 et à 2
faire une attaque sur le roi et la tour
en g8 aurait même pu essayer d'aller sur
laquelle j'ai trois par la suite
et comment on va le voir dans une petite
analyse le fou aussi va prendre part à
la tacc puisqu'il va passer aussi et
bien sûr sur les cases noires donc par
exemple sur le ku'damm f2 pour afin de
ramener peut-être le cavalier h2 sur la
case f3 pour revenir en défense c'était
l'idée du coquillage le et aussi pour
anticiper évidemment la taille de la
tour en g3 les noirs jouent bien sûr le
coût d'un bep 2 est sur le coup roi des
huns
alors on a la possibilité bien sûr
d'aller prendre le pion déjà on a deux
tout simplement mais il ya beaucoup
mieux c'est du coup b5 ici qui permettra
aux fous de venir en a cinq pour créer
une attaque de maths attaques de maths
probablement imparable parce que même
après le ku'damm d2 les noirs jouent
quand même le coup fou à 5
sacrifice de fou et si les blancs
prennent ce flou ils vont se faire mater
ou alors ils vont perdre la dame grâce
au coût d'un bep un échec et sur roi
abdallah
la tour descend pas tout de suite mais
le pion est pris à près d'un français
deux échecs et si les blues ramènent la
demande et de la tour arrive en g2 est
bien la dame bien sûr dans les autres
cas ce serait matt donc déjà une un gain
de la part de magnus carlsen garate ici
euros 35 34e co mais c'est pas fini
puisque les noirs conserve quand même un
très bon avantage après le pot h5 on se
retrouve après tout rêve de d'alger à la
dame qui rentre dans le camp des noms et
des blancs mais du côté roy un petit peu
moins d'espacé elle n'attaque pas les
pions de l'ale dame
donc c'est un petit peu moins efficace
mais c'est quand même plutôt plutôt bon
pour les noirs évidemment cavalli f1 h4
roi des 2 3 des 7 ces trois fois 5 on
voit les pièces noires qui sont
extrêmement actives laurent blanc qui
tente de se cacher du côté dames
protéger le cavalier en f1 qui vient
bloquer évidemment la dame noire
le cavalier qu'il y a aussi bloqué
l'entrée de la tour en g3 même si
c'était une possibilité quand même pour
les noirs devenir sacrifier les qualités
carrément pour se créer un pion passé
pourquoi pas mais ici il y avait un bon
coup encore au 39e coup les noirs
avaient le très fort coup au lieu du
ku'damm g7 qui a été jouée le très
fourbe et 5 qui permettait de menacer le
coupé quatre pour ouvrir complètement
les cases noires et ouvrait enfin la
diagonale du fou noir pour par la suite
faire une batterie enlever le fou et
amener la dame pour attaquer le roi dont
classes étaient extrêmement extrêmement
puissants comme coup il a préféré le
coup dame g7 au 39e coup peut-être
juste avant la fin du zef note
les blancs ont joué cavalier age ii est
là finalement il a pris le pion c3 et ça
c'était probablement l'erreur décisif
qui virent on lève les victoires il y
avait encore la possibilité de revenir
tout simplement avec la dame angers 1
pour répéter les coups finalement on
peut répéter les courants si on répète
que deux fois en fait pagnol il faut
pour faire du bien il faut répéter trois
fois les coûts évidemment la dame menace
de rentrer en un donc ça c'est quand
même très embêtant comme menace donc il
faut il faut quand même le paraît donc
il n'y a pas énormément choix pour parer
cette menace a pas ramené le cavalier en
f1 et là on se retrouve avec le coupé 5
finalement dans la partie dans au 40e
coup les noirs ont pris le pion c3 ce
qui permet aux blancs de récupérer le
pion f4 et de force et par la suite les
changes des dames avec dame f cet échec
il ya eu food et qu'adam et eve cet
échec
voici ce dont vous êtes tous reproches à
sept et on se retrouve dans une finale
qui est quand même supérieur pour les
noirs mais qui n'est plus gagnante
le fou quand même et de couleur noire
donc il peut pas attaquer les pions
adverse mais le couple tour est fou et
peut même meilleur que le koup'tou orque
cavaillé dans cette finale
les les pions blancs sont quand même
attaquable par la tour le roi blanc est
assez faible il ya un avantage noir mais
pas suffisant pour gagner
et évidemment comme comme souvent même
jusqu'à recèle va essayer le plus
possible pour pour gagner il va pas
réussir au 115e coup enfin là nul sera
conclu dans cette partie on passe
maintenant directement à la deuxième
partie entre magnus carsen et fabiano
caruana évidemment les couleurs sont
inversés maintenant magnus carlsen à
l'eiblen voici la position critique dans
laquelle on se retrouve après une
ouverture un peu compliqué pour les
blancs finalement et obtient une
position
récente même si on s'aperçoit ici dans
cette position au 20e coup pour après le
coup de l'homme ccdh des noirs pas mal
de faiblesse chez les blancs un pion
isolé en c3 un autre pur isolant à 4 est
un pion même s'il n'est pas vraiment
faible en cinq mais qui est sous
pression de l'adamant c7 et le coup donc
le coût d'accès 7 qui vient attaquer ce
pion justement aux 5
on s'attendait un coût qui défend depuis
ont évidemment un tourin par exemple
pour défend le pion c'est pas agréable
c'est un coup un peu passif bien sûr
magnus carlsen ne va pas choisir ce coup
il préfère un coût plus plus active plus
agressif avec le coutour b1 pour contre
attaquer sur le pion 17 pions bessette
qui ne pourra pas être pris si jamais
des noirs prennent le pion à 5,1
parce que sur d'impro 5 évidemment si on
prend pions 17ème 1 on va se faire mais
tu es fou qu'on bessette faucon bessèges
te reprends des sectes dames 1 matt
directement évidemment on va pas faire
ça mais sur d'impro 5 l'idée c'était de
récupérer la colonne ouverte
probablement en mettant la dame en
premier un sur la colonne en jouant md2
peut-être dam des trois était possible
s'ils voient retour des 1
l'idée c'est de récupérer la colonne
ouverte pour menacer de rentrer avec la
dame
et si la dame noire revient pour essayer
de compte empêcher la dame blanche de
venir cette fois on met les tours pour
faire une batterie et du cou rentré
quand même avec la pièce lourde sur la
caisse des 8 qu'est ce qui va se passer
dans ces cas là et moi ça va bloquer
complètement les pièces noir puisque le
foncier 8 ne peut plus bouger et la tour
on a huit non plus du coup parce que
vous évite le
locke donc une compensation suffisante
pour le pion de retard donc un joli coup
tomber un la suite avec donc dans ce 21e
coût pour les noirs tourbe et 8 pour
défendre le pion en baissse est donc
probablement avec il est de prendre
quand même le pion aux 5 malgré tout
voir si on veut pas le prendre tout de
suite de jouer peut-être le coup b6 afin
de sortir le fou par exemple en 17 ou
bien de sortir aussi le fou en 17 et
devenir par exemple l'échangé on sait si
ça l'idée dé noir évidemment serait
d'échangés ce fou qui est quand même
bloqué et ensuite d'attaquer les pions
faible des blancs tomber 8 dan des trois
ans la halle et blanc récupère tout de
suite la colonne alors là aussi les
blancs les noirs auraient pu prendre le
pion aux cinq ans faisant donc d'un
prend le 5 mai les naines blanches
serait rentré en des huit d'un des huit
échecs ou h7 seul coup et dames 7 avec
une position très actif de pièces pour
les blancs qui attaque du même coup deux
pions puisque les pions f7 et v7 sont
attaqués alors bessette ne peut pas être
pris tout de suite toujours à cause du
mode du couloir mais il suffira aux
blancs peut-être de jouer un petit coup
de pions h3 où j'ai trois pour éviter le
matin afin de menacer ce pion pion qui
aura du mal à bouger parce que la dame
recette vient coût 3 les la septième
rangée 1 et donc la tacc par exemple sur
le pion à 7 derrière donc une âme très
active qui empêche les pièces nord de
bouger tout ça pour un pion seulement
c'est probablement une très bonne
commence à sion et les lois ont eu
raison finalement ne pas prendre ce pion
donc après dan détroit food et s'est
tranquillement les noirs ou quand même
un avantage de structures de pions dont
qu'ils espèrent peut-être valoriser en
finale food et 7 à 5 pour éviter l'
attaque sur le pion à alors possibilité
pour les blancs s'étaient directement de
faire le coup d'aller 6 d'indécis ce
demander si ce pan des six fou prend 1,4
et la tour prend bessette éventuellement
mais c'est un peu dangereux
la finale le fou de même couleur et
dangereuse puisque bien que les noirs
des papillons d'avancé ils ont quand
même hein
puis ont passé et éloigné puis on va
s'éloigner par rapport au roi blanc
alors c'est vrai que les blancs ou aussi
des pions passé mais le roi noir est
plus près de ces purs ont donc une
finale peut-être un peu dangereuse il a
préféré jouer le coup à cinq lits si
fous ces six donc pour échanger le fou
comme prévu et là maintenant des médicis
d'anne decis dame prend des 6e prend des
six fours en f3 on a l'impression que
cet affaiblissement pions et est
extrêmement préjudiciable pour les
blancs mais finalement on se retrouve
dans une structure où les pions de les
droits sont pas si mal puisque la
majorité des noirs du côté droit aura
beaucoup plus de difficultés à créer un
pion passé avec ses pions doublé du fait
des pluies ont doublé et pion qui
contrôle de chaque côté de sûr aussi
bien sur la colonne eux que sur la
colonne jets vont rendre la création
d'un pion passé difficile dans la finale
j'éprouve trois rois et fuite alors les
noirs doivent absolument évidemment
contrer le pion passé en des six ans
maintenant le roi c'est le problème du
pion passé au centre c'est que le roi
peut revenir évidemment très rapidement
ces quatre pour venir le défendre avec
l'autre pions en 8 es là il a décidé de
jouer à 6 tout de suite pour jouer sur
le clouage du pion efforts c'est
probablement le coup b6 alors un autre
coup un place de et si c'était le pouce
et 5 1 avec donc il est de défendre le
pion évidemment menace de faire ces six
puisque le plan b 7 et cloud et donc le
coût des noirs seraient forcés ces deux
jeux roi 17 pour l'empêcher et là les
blancs peuvent jouer maintenant à six et
dans ce cas là probablement sait il
pourrait y avoir une finale de pions
assez dangereuse après le court à ces
six approuvé cette tour prend b737
reprend 17 avec deux pions passé lié
évidemment on a l'impression que les
blancs ou une bonne position
sauf que les lois auront le pian passé
éloignés et ça c'est encore plus
dangereux
parce que laurent blanc va être obligé
déjà de rentrer dans le carré du pion en
faisant aurait fait 3 6 6 pour bloquer
les pions re 2 e et les noirs ont quand
même une majorité du côté roi comme on a
dit mais cette majorité risque d'être
bloqué par les pions blancs donc
probablement la position est nul dans
cette finale de pions mais ça aurait été
très compliqué donc eu raison de ne pas
rentrer là-dedans et donc au 28e coup il
a préféré jouer le coup à six pour
forcer vous allez voir une finale deux
tours finale deux tours inférieur avec
les blancs mais une finale de tournoi
quand même après b6 ça c'est un coup
fort c'est sinon les blancs comprend le
pion 17
ces cinq rois 17 le pion b6 est toujours
floue et il faut absolument bloquer
l'avancée du pion c'est sans raccourci 6
3 17 s'éprend b61 prend b6 là aussi
s'efforcer il faut surtout pas prendre
de la tour parce qu'après les changes
détour le pion à 6 irait adam à sept
tours à huit typhons peu gestion d' adam
évidemment en v6 3.7 ici finalement ce
sont les noirs qui ont davantage parce
que le pion des six est condamné mais la
finale quatre pions contre trois sur les
droits et finale est une île dans une
finale deux tours
ja on peut pas faire grand chose
évidemment à ce niveau là ils vont pas
faire d'erreur et donc yvon avaient ils
vont quand même joué un peu mais ils
vont faire nul évidemment à un autre
niveau 1 et la finale pour être
dangereuse pour les blancs mais ici ils
vont faire nul assez vite finalement ils
feront nul au 49e coup après roy g2e 5
les noirs tente évidemment de jouer le
cours a eu 6 suivi de joux et au retour
17 pour aller prendre le pion des six
pions des six qui est de toute façon ne
pourra pas être défendue 1 il a défendu
que par la tour donc le pion est
condamné mais les finales sera nul avec
quatre pions contre 3 voilà donc
finalement deux nuls dans ses deux
premières parties
on peut dire que fabiano caruana dans la
première partie a eu chaud a eu très
chaud et par contre ils avaient
davantage dans la deuxième mais sans
avoir quand même de possibilités de
gagner cette partie
en tout cas les noirs à chaque fois
qu'ils obtiennent de bonnes positions
donc de bonne préparation a priori pour
les jeux pour les joueurs avec les noirs
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette ce
résumé de ses deux premières parties et
à bientôt pour les parties 3 et 4